Frozen 2 has been a hit with both adults and
kids alike, and although the movie has plenty
of slapstick comedy for little ones to enjoy,
it also includes some eyebrow-raising grown-up
jokes and references as well.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers, I'm Jan and in
this video, I'm revealing the 12 most surprising
and shocking adult gags and details that Disney's
animators snuck into Frozen 2.
"Come on, it'll be fun!"
There will be spoilers, so take care if you
haven't seen the movie yet.
"It began with two sisters."
When Kristoff sings about proposing to Anna
during 'Some Things Never Change', he gets
down on one knee and holds up a ring directly
in front of Sven who nods vigorously in reply.
But it's the reaction of the on-lookers to
this scene that makes this a priceless adult
joke, as they clearly think that Kristoff
has taken his theory that 'Reindeer are better
than people' a step too far and is actually
asking one to marry him!
One horrified woman puts her hand in front
of her young daughter's eyes to stop her seeing
what's happening.
While another woman not only turns her head
away from Kristoff and Sven but, as an extra
precaution, also blocks her eyes with her
hand.
This isn't the first time the unusual connection
between Kristoff and Sven has been referred
to in the Frozen franchise.
In the first movie, the Trolls poked fun at
their special relationship when they sang
the 'Fixer-Upper' song which included Kristoff's
various flaws such as
'his thing with the reindeer.
That's a little outside of nature's laws!'
"That's normal."
In Frozen 2, Kristoff is of course devoted
to Anna, but the new film still has some funny
callbacks to the original movie’s romantic
tension between the pair.
For example, Elsa and Olaf fall asleep on
their cart ride to the Enchanted Forest, and
as soon as Anna notices they're no longer
awake, she asks Kristoff what he'd like to
do!
It's clear from both her tone and body language
when she asks the question, and the fact that
she leans in for a kiss, that she's got loving
on her mind.
"Yes!"
And then when Kristoff, Olaf, and Sven get
all dressed up in fancy outfits for a special
occasion at the end of the movie, Kristoff
just isn't comfortable with his new clothes,
and tells Anna, 'You get this for one hour'.
That's when Anna whispers her rather racy
reply to him, 'That's ok, I prefer you in
leather anyway!'
"Charmed, I'm sure."
That's followed by even more double-entendres
as Olaf's innocent comment to Kristoff that
'I'm shocked you can last an hour' will doubtless
be understood by some adults watching as a
reference to something other than the character's
smart new clothes, especially given Anna's
previous comment about leather.
"Don't patronise me."
After the gang encounter the wind spirit in
the Enchanted Forest, it lifts Olaf up in
the air, twirling him around playfully.
And as he whirls around, his bottom half billows
out around him, like a dress caught in the
breeze.
This is a tribute to the iconic scene in director
Billy Wilders' film The Seven Year Itch where
Marilyn Monroe's white dress blows up around
her after a blast of air from a subway grate.
And Olaf even remarks that the breezy experience
is 'delicious', just like Monroe did in the
1955 classic comedy about marital infidelity.
"Ooh, do you feel the breeze from the subway?
Isn't it delicious?"
Later, when Olaf first introduces himself
to the people trapped in the Forest, Ryder
gasps and hides behind his sister Honeymaren.
"Who are you?"
"Hi, I'm Olaf."
Although Ryder's clearly shocked to meet a
talking snowman, that never occurs to Olaf
who thinks the problem is something quite
different.
"Oh!
Sorry, yeah I just find clothes restricting."
Yes, Olaf believes that Ryder's so stunned
when they meet because he thinks the little
snowman isn't wearing any clothes!
So, now we know for sure that, despite the
three stones resembling buttons on his front,
Olaf actually prefers to go au naturel!
And just before we get to Elsa's hilarious
adult moment in Frozen 2, I want to let you
know that thanks to this video's sponsor NordVPN,
all our viewers can get a very special Black
Friday deal of 84% off, plus 4 bonus months
for free, and free access to the NordLocker
file encryption app, by free by visiting NordVPN.com/Flicks
or tapping the link in the video description.
Frozen 2 pokes fun at a particularly iconic
moment from the first movie.
After Elsa's "Show Yourself" song, Ahtohallan
reveals memories to her of past events including
childhood games with Anna and the Duke of
Weselton dancing.
But when she sees the memory of herself strutting
her stuff during Let It Go, it makes her visibly
cringe.
It's an amusing moment of Elsa feeling embarrassed
at the actions of her younger self, something
many adults will be able to relate to.
But there's a second level to this joke as
not only is it about having outgrown your
younger self, it may also be a wink to those
in the audience who saw or heard that song
so many times it ended up driving them crazy!
That same moment from Let It Go was also parodied
earlier in the sequel when Olaf imitated Elsa's
signature self-assured sashay during a game
of charades.
"Ooh, Elsa!"
The sequel also remedies complaints from fans
that Kristoff never got a full song of his
own in the first movie.
"Reindeers are better than people.
Sven, why is love so hard?"
This time Kristoff gets to belt out his very
own love song called Lost In The Woods.
It's all about his struggles to move forward
in his relationship with Anna and there's
plenty about this new musical number that's
aimed specifically at adults.
There's the whole retro style of the song,
which is basically a take on 80s power ballads.
According to Kristen Anderson-Lopez, one half
of the husband-and-wife song-writing team
behind Frozen's mega hits, 'The 1980s was
that brief moment in music when men were allowed
to sing those big power ballads – and to
be vulnerable while doing it.'
Personally, when I watched the film, Lost
In The Woods had a strong feel of Peter Cetera
and Chicago's 80s power ballads, like Glory
of Love, the theme for The Karate Kid Part
2, and You're The Inspiration, which featured
in Deadpool.
But the 80s vibe of Lost In The Woods doesn't
end with the music.
Kristoff also gets the 80s music video treatment,
complete with music video wind for that signature
romantic breeze.
Between the visuals and the song itself, the
Lost In The Woods sequence nicely balances
amusing images, perfect for a retro music
video, with Kristoff's very real sincerity
as he sings about his love for Anna.
And speaking of classic music videos, it seems
the Frozen 2 team had one particularly famous
music video in mind when they were animating
Lost In The Woods.
The way Sven and several other reindeer appear
as backing singers around Kristoff during
his new power ballad channels the look of
the ground-breaking promotional video that
Queen made in 1975 for their super-hit Bohemian
Rhapsody.
The British rock band's video has been so
influential that it's credited with "practically
inventing the music video", and many adults
in the Frozen 2 audience will immediately
spot some of its signature style as Sven and
his fellow quadrupeds orbit Kristoff as they
provide reindeer harmonies for his lead vocals.
Fun fact: as well as voicing Kristoff, actor
Jonathan Groff also voices all the reindeer
in the song!
"You feel what you feel.
And those feelings are real.
Come on Kristoff, let down your guard."
When Elsa and Anna discover their parents'
shipwreck in the Enchanted Lands, they wonder
why and how their parents ended up there.
Anna has the idea to look for answers in the
waterproof compartment that every Arendellian
ship has.
Which prompts Olaf to muse, 'that's very clever;
although it does make me wonder why they don't
just make the whole ship waterproof.'
This is actually a sly joke about aeroplanes
and their flight recorders, aka black boxes,
which are designed specifically to survive
airplane crashes so the flight data they store
can be used by accident investigators to determine
the cause of a crash.
A fact which often leads people to joke: why
aren't aeroplanes made from the same material
as black boxes?!
One of the main themes that runs throughout
the film is change and how we adapt to it
and Olaf is a crucial character in getting
that point across.
"How I wish this could last forever.
Hmmm!
And yet change mocks us with her beauty."
Olaf was a bundle of innocence when we met
him in the first film, however now, instead
of dreaming up plans for summertime, Olaf
is trying to come to terms with the many changes
happening around him.
"Tell me, you're older and thus all-knowing.
Do you ever worry about the notion that nothing
is permanent?"
What's especially amusing for adults in the
audience is that Olaf really believes that
everything he's going through and life in
general will all make sense when he's grown
up!
In fact, Olaf's song 'When I Am Older' includes
a lot of lines that adults will doubtless
find funny, such as:
'I'll have all the answers when I'm older';
'When I'm more mature, I'll feel totally secure',
and 'when you're older, absolutely everything
makes sense'.
Grown-up viewers will find the irony of Olaf's
song comical as they know getting older doesn't
always mean you understand everything better,
sometimes things just seem even more ridiculous.
"Well, you're the grown-ups you'd know."
And adults will also laugh because they'll
probably remember they thought the same as
Olaf when they were kids too!
In the three years between the events of the
two movies, Olaf has been reading and learning
a lot, and he drives the other characters
a little crazy on their journey north with
his fascinating facts that range from the
chances of getting struck by lightning to
the shape of wombat poop.
But the little snowman has even begun to ponder
some weightier, philosophical ideas.
"Hey, let me ask you.
How do you guys cope with ever-increasing
complexity of thought that comes with maturity?
Oh, no, no, don't chew that, you don't know
what I've stepped in."
In the Enchanted Forest, when Anna asks Olaf
for some help in understanding the mysterious
ice sculptures created by Elsa's magic, just
before he gets to his "water has memory" explanation,
Olaf mentions his theory "about advancing
technologies [being] both our saviour and
our doom."
Many adults will find this reference both
humorous and true given the real-life benefits
and threats that stem from our ever-advancing
technological world, whether that's connecting
with friends and accessing information and
entertainment in just a few clicks, or actors
brought back from the dead to star in new
movies, driverless vehicles, and the rise
of artificial intelligence.
Perhaps Olaf's philosophical ponderings about
technology could even make a funny and informative
short series, along the lines of Forky Asks
A Question, where Olaf learns, for example,
how to stay safe online and protect his privacy.
And actually that's something NordVPN, who
offer one of the world's best virtual private
networks, could help him with.
If you want to secure yourself from hackers,
malicious websites and [even] your own internet
service provider selling your online browsing
history to advertisers, then a VPN is essential.
A VPN creates a secure, encrypted tunnel between
your device and a VPN server, stopping your
ISP or any other agencies from tracking you
online, reading your emails, private messages
or what websites you're visiting.
Unlike free VPNs, Nord is super-fast with
more than 5,000 servers in over 60 countries;
and when I put it to the test, I was still
able to get blisteringly fast download speeds
over my home connection.
NordVPN is also great in helping you bypass
any blocks on videos or websites which aren't
viewable in your country.
With NordVPN, you can quickly pick a server
in any country and then browse the internet
as if you were there.
Nord's VPN even unlocks Netflix shows that
may not be available in your home country.
The interface is amazingly intuitive and you
can connect up to six devices at the same
time so you can keep your mobile devices and
laptops safe whenever you're travelling or
using insecure public wifi in a coffee shop,
for example.
On top of that, NordVPN offers a unique feature
called CyberSec which provides ad blocking
and protection against malware, and Nord has
a no-log policy meaning it doesn't record
any of your browsing.
With our special Black Friday and Cybermonth
deal, NordVPN are offering all our viewers
up to 84% off new subscriptions, plus an additional
four months free, and free access to the NordLocker
file encryption app.
Just visit NordVPN.com/Flicks or tap the link
in the video description to access the offer.
For just the price of a monthly cup of coffee
you can secure your internet browsing from
spies and hackers.
That's NordVPN.com/Flicks for a huge 84% discount
plus four months entirely free.
Now, what were your favourite moments or jokes
in Frozen 2?
Let me know in the comments below.
Next tap left to learn all about Elsa's new
powers in Frozen 2 or tap right for another
video you're sure to like.
And if you enjoyed this, remember to share
and leave a thumbs-up for more videos like
this.
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!